It’s an old adage that money makes the world
go round, and when you work for the SCP Foundation,
that same money can keep the world from ending.
Think for a second about the kind of absurd
bills that the SCP Foundation racks up: They
need to pay for the upkeep on hundreds of
facilities while also paying for thousands
of employees - As well as stipends for the
families of the many, many, many members of
personnel who are killed in the line of duty.
They also need to pay for the equipment required
to do their jobs - a lot of which they need
to develop themselves - as well as the expenses
of varied containment procedures for well
over 6000 different anomalies, each one requiring
its own unique treatment.
And that’s not even factoring in the costs
of their various experiments, vehicles, weaponry,
and cover-up operations.
To say the Foundation would need billions
upon billions of dollars to do what they do
is probably low-balling it.
So today, we feel like asking the big question.
How does the SCP Foundation make all this
money?
Because personally, we just don’t think
the bi-annual Foundation bake sale is going
to cover the price tag on this thing.
First, we’re going to explore the different
ways the Foundation probably brings in its
obscene budget through more traditional means,
but if you stick around to the end, we’ll
explore some of the much more strange and
exciting ways the Foundation can financially
exploit its vast cache of anomalies, as well
as a way that you - that’s right, YOU!
- can help.
So buckle up as we tackle the most terrifying
monster of all: Budgeting.
The most obvious means the Foundation has
of scraping up a little extra cash is its
cooperation with world governments.
Obviously, the SCP Foundation isn’t a puppet
of the United Nations like the GOC, it operates
with a high degree of autonomy that prevents
its work from ever being biased by certain
national or international interests.
However, in order to do its work properly,
it does collaborate with various governments
across the globe.
Naturally, as a result of this, it does receive
assisted funding from governments when combating
or containing anomalies that would present
a threat to their national security.
Think of it as a classic “You scratch my
back, I scratch yours” situation.
But seeing as people would notice every single
government on earth farming out billions of
dollars for seemingly no reason that the public
could account for, it’s clear that this
only accounts for one of the SCP Foundation’s
multiple income streams.
Where else is all the money coming from?
Well, a phrase you’ve probably heard a lot
on the videos on this channel is “Front
Businesses.”
As any members of the Mafia in our audience
will already know, a front business is a seemingly
legitimate company used to hide the operations
of a more secretive or illicit business going
on behind the scenes.
Typically, it’s a boon for organized crime
syndicates who need to justify the purchases
of certain personnel or equipment or launder
ill-gotten gains into clean, legitimate, taxable
revenue streams.
Cause trust us, kids, the only three letters
scarier than SCP are IRS.
The SCP Foundation makes use of a huge number
of front organizations to both hide its operations
and supplement its income.
From chemical plants to office buildings to
local bakeries, it’s impossible to know
just how many normal industries technically
answer to the O5 Council high enough up the
chain.
For all you know, you could already be an
employee of the SCP Foundation without even
being aware of it.
Income generated by the various front companies
used by the Foundation are likely to make
up a good chunk of their budget.
Another key factor in the Foundation’s profitability
is technology.
Given that the Foundation has gathered some
of the greatest scientific and engineering
minds in the world to protect humanity from
anomalous forces, it goes without saying that
they create some incredible technology, which
may later trickle down into wider commercial
and civilian use.
And before you start to say this is crazy,
it’s actually an incredibly common practice
with regular militaries all over the world.
Duct tape, super glue, GPS, silly putty, EpiPens,
microwaves, and the internet were all made
possible by military advancements.
And with the Foundation having technology
so advanced it puts even the most well-funded
militaries to shame, it’s sure to have some
similar lucrative patents floating around
out there.
Not to mention the fact that the Foundation
has also reclaimed and repurposed anomalous
technology that surpasses even their own,
which may influence some incredibly profitable
consumer goods further down the line.
Which is a nice segue to the next portion
of this video: Utilizing captured anomalies
for fun and profit!
Well, mostly profit, in this case.
This is the much more fun and theoretical
half of things, where we speculate on which
SCPs would bring in the biggest bucks to fill
the coffers of the SCP Foundation.
And of course, stick around to the end for
the most important money-making method of
all.
It won’t be what you expect...
First, SCP-096.
We know what you’re thinking: How do we
monetize a mindless killing machine?
Simple, we stand someone in front of it and
make them look at its face, then position
096 onto a treadmill attached to a series
of powerful generators.
Given that 096 literally never gets tired,
we will have invented a true perpetual motion
machine, and the energy generated by this
could replace the municipal power grid.
That’s surely gotta be worth a few bucks,
right?
United States Government, the Foundation awaits
your call.
Okay, okay, let’s get a little more serious.
Have you ever heard the expression “a penny
saved is a penny earned”?
Because as previously discussed, one of the
major costs of the Foundation is labor.
However, SCP-662 - The Butler’s Hand Bell
that summons the unfailingly loyal Mr. Deeds
- could solve this issue.
You may be thinking, “Sure, Mr. Deeds can
replace the labor of a couple of people, but
not that many!
He’s got physical limitations!”
To which we would answer: What about SCP-662
put through SCP-914, The Clockworks, on Fine?
We’d wager that this might lead to a bell
that summons an even more effective Mr. Deeds,
or better yet, multiple Mr. Deeds.
You could only imagine the money the SCP Foundation
would save.
Upon request, he can also manifest bricks
of pure gold.
He’s a butler that literally pays for himself!
But enough about Mr. Deeds, let’s talk about
you: Are you happy?
Fulfilled?
Do you know why you’re here?
A lot of people struggle with finding a sense
of purpose in life.
It can make it difficult to form and actualize
your goals.
If only it was easy to know your greatest
desire, so you could finally get your life
together and start working on it.
Thankfully, the Foundation could help...For
a price.
What?
You can’t blame them for a little #hustle.
With SCP-978, the Desire Camera, they could
help people figure out what their deepest
desire is.
But that’s not the only way to make money
from this anomalous device.
By taking pictures of the rich and powerful,
and seeing if their desires are compromising,
humiliating, or even illegal, you can quickly
solicit some very generous donations out of
them in exchange for keeping this juicy information
under wraps.
Podcasts are big these days - with incredibly
popular ones like the Joe Rogan Experience
getting around eleven million downloads per
episode.
People love hearing a compelling interview
or a good story.
That’s why, to make a little money on the
side, we recommend the Foundation gives SCP-1867
- a talkative telepathic sea slug who goes
by Lord Blackwood - his own podcast, where
he would spin wild yarns, interview celebrity
guests, and perhaps even host chats with other
interesting SCPs - All while the Foundation
cleans up on sweet, sweet podcast sponsorship
revenue.
What, are you telling us you wouldn’t tune
in?
SCP-5094, Miss J’s Whiz Kid Schoolhouse,
could also be converted into expensive, over-the-counter
proprietary software.
Think of the money that companies like Skillshare
and Masterclass rake in.
Miss J could guarantee perfect learning through
her intensive courses, and once the word of
her efficacy spreads, she might even replace
traditional higher education.
And who would be the financial beneficiary?
The SCP Foundation.
Then there’s SCP-2430, the Immortal Hitler
Clone.
He’s unable to die, but feels pain at a
heightened degree of sensitivity than most
normal people.
He’s also...Hitler.
And if the Foundation were able to go public
about the existence of this clone, they could
take him out on tour across the globe, and
charge ten to fifteen bucks to punch him.
People would be lining up to take a crack
at the ex-fuhrer, and the Foundation would,
of course, be the sole financial beneficiaries.
Now let’s talk about pizza.
The most popular pizza chain in the United
States, as of this writing, is Domino’s,
with annual revenue of just over fourteen
billion dollars.
What we’re wondering is: Why doesn’t the
SCP Foundation want a slice of that lucrative
pizza pie?
After all, they’re in possession of SCP-458,
the Never-Ending Pizza Box.
With the help of this bad boy - capable of
producing nearly limitless quantities of pizza
- they could surely start making a pretty
pepperoni penny.
Lego products are also a multi-billion dollar
industry, pointing towards a clear desire
in the market for those charming, colorful
blocks, and there’s no lego like SCP-387,
the Living Lego.
Hardcore Lego enthusiasts all over the world
would pay through the nose to experience a
product like this, and seeing as they’re
completely Safe - in both SCP nomenclature
and the more colloquial sense of the phrase
- the Foundation wouldn’t need to worry
about any lawsuits from concerned parents.
They’d only need to worry about where to
put all their fancy new stacks of cold, hard
cash!
For those desiring a little escapism, the
Foundation could rent out SCP-1230, A Hero
Is Born.
This book takes its readers on fabulous bespoke
dream adventures through fantastical lands,
and will surely give them an experience that
will last long after they finally wake up.
In a world where people are willing to pay
top dollar for VR Experiences and creepy Facebook
Meta-Verses, being able to enter the wondrous
land of dreams is a welcome low-tech solution
that would still likely make the SCP Foundation
boatloads of new income.
We live in a stressful world.
Modern life has not only come with its wealth
of new personal issues, from work troubles
to the dating game.
And connectivity has come at the cost of having
an ever-greater awareness of the troubles
that plague the world at large.
With costs making a lot of valuable therapy
and medications unavailable to many, it’s
no wonder that we’re undergoing a global
mental health crisis.
But the Foundation has a solution: SCP-999.
Spend long enough time with him, and he’ll
straight up cure everything from depression
to PTSD.
People all over the world would pay top dollar
to achieve an immediate and effective cure
to all mental maladies that only takes a few
hours, and has no negative side effects.
Like the ultimate therapy dog.
The Foundation would be rolling in the dough
from an opportunity like this.
And of course, the most devious, ingenious,
and overall effective method that the SCP
Foundation could possibly use to make money
is creating YouTube channels that pretend
to just be sharing the fictional monsters
and entities of a made-up online fiction project.
When, in fact, they’re actually secretly
leaking the highly classified secrets of their
own organization, while selling adorable,
high-quality merchandise of some of their
most lovable and iconic creatures.
We can’t think of any method more valuable
than that.
Anyway, on a completely different note, did
you know you can get your very own adorable
SCP-999 plushie, pictured here looking cute
as all heck?
All you need to do is visit www.scpswag.com,
and you can have your very own Tickle Monster
to hug any time you please!
And of course, if there are any other highly
profitable anomalies you’d like to see in
plush form, do take the time to make your
suggestions heard down in the comments.
Now, if you’ll excuse us, we need to head
off.
After all, time is money.
Now go check out “SCP Foundation Boss - The
Administrator Explained” and “Top 8 SCP
Objects You Actually Want” for more esoteric
questions about the inner workings of the
SCP Foundation and its anomalies!